the body of hiker Rock Stanley was found  this morning members of his family  announced it Stanley went missing after  a morning hike Saturday August 23rd now  we spoke with Red Rocks search and  rescue and they sell us 12 searches  totaling more than 1400 man hours went  to finding him for them offering the  family closure is a big deal  super important to get answers for the  family so they're not sitting there for  months and years waiting and wondering  what happened to their loved one and it  allows them to be to begin the grieving  process and to to continue on with life  he went on to tell us that Stanley was  found at the bottom of a steep slope  they're unsure of how he died but they  don't believe that Foul Play was a  factor